he was told that you have to guarantee
top four football to get a loan he was
told that when he didn't know where we
would end up and he did that for 22
years i went clock i rate liverpool so
it's like them saying when klopp comes
in listen jurgen you have to work within
a budget you can't buy van dyke you
can't buy ellison we're building a new
stadium you've got to guarantee that
liverpool will be in the top four
for the longs to come even though klopp
does not know where liverpool end up
this is why i'm saying who's a better
manager
[Music]
hello toy hello what's happening mate
what's going on how are you doing you're
five first how are you
that's good
how are you feeling do you have five
fats how are you feeling good yeah i'm
feeling pretty good after last night
especially after after last night
so how are you feeling after that 89 oh
no you know i don't remember do this
would you remember from that i remember
that we won the league oh amazing
amazing it was amazing we started
already we are starting
already
thank you thank you
liverpool are a bigger club than arsenal
three two one
where you going
is it obvious
i mean
why are you going there why are you
going there well i don't know where
should i start i don't know if i've got
enough fingers on my hands yeah toes
fingers
you could start wherever you want
why do you start after that you know how
about that okay we can start anfield 89
okay
so that's why you're a bigger club than
us because anfield united
that's what that's you i said why don't
you stop that's not why we can start
from over why should we start at anfield
okay so i don't get that okay so we
start at 9 30 then how about that we can
start wherever you want okay so let's go
and we can
okay so let's go back to the night phase
what did you win the knife oh my god toy
are you no i thought i think you're a
big club right now are you a big club i
use bigger we'll always be a big club
always because
always because because of what makes you
the club no no we've won six champions
leagues we've won we've got multiple
teams we've won we won the most ever
comes we want to leave all traffic we
want to leave
okay so you won three leagues in the
night phase which you which i'm going
back to can you go back to my face if
you want to tell
[Music]
he was a bigger club in herbert
chapman's era there you go you've won is
that you've won the olympia so he wasn't
a big club in 2004
i've just said to you you was a big he
wasn't a bigger club in 2004 no he
wasn't you yeah we had an invisible team
but we were in the bigger club
unfortunately
unfortunately having an invincible's
trophy the greatest the greatest the
greatest it took you 30 years to win the
league
i i just don't know what you're basing
it on honestly i'm asking you if it's
not a fact i don't know i'm basing on
facts so the fact is 1989 no sorry in
1999 99 when you last won the league i
was 20. and then you didn't win the
league until cups ago when i was 51.
right do you know that yes so then so
don't say well you know your age but i
know all the facts so you know that time
you mean to tell me that in 1990 he was
a bigger cub than us i was going to to
we won the league somehow somehow i
don't think i don't think the lads have
asked us
in which period was who was a bigger
club i think they said i just think they
made my statement
i say you will that's not a problem i'm
getting used to it
ty the reason why i strongly agree that
we're a bigger club than you is in terms
of global fan base
um marketing all around the world
sponsorship deals
league trophies
fa cup trophies
uh champions league in terms of
the combination of all not just i know
you've won the most fa cups etc etc fair
play but the fact that we've won six
champions leagues on top of the many
more leagues that we've won the new
makes us
absolutely the bigger club out of the
two that's just my opinion that's just
some of the facts that i want to bring
to the table so look um
the the the value of our club yeah
how how how much is arsenal worth right
now
about
i'd say
800 billion something
that's the maybe the most 800
so liverpool was valued at uh recently
forbes by four billion okay um and that
is that is well that's
that's very very sick much significantly
bigger than arsenal's you've won the fa
cup you've seen the most times you've
reminded me in like five months you've
reminded me about more than how many
times you've won the cup the second time
you reminded me you won the fa cup can
you remind me how many times you've won
the biggest club trophy
there is
can you remember how many invincibles
you have only if you answer my question
first which is relevant to the point
okay so you've got an invisible team
i'll just ask you a question man like
you've got it no no because i don't know
you can answer your own questions
have you got an invisible team that
would be an answer if you can answer
that question there's your answer have
we got an invincible team yes no i don't
i don't i so that's your answer you said
no sure sure
you're also awesome okay so what's
what's your answer so what you just said
is though we don't have a european we
don't have a we don't have a new pickup
you don't have any visibility does that
make you does it make you a bigger club
than liverpool then in that case because
you haven't got one i mean if you have
them you haven't got an invisible team
the question is i don't know where the
question is
is this confusing no no that's not is
that confusing always very confusing
you make it very wrong
is this coming you can't mistake you for
a spurs fan i know okay
what i'm confused about is i don't think
you heard the statement i heard the
statement fine i heard the statement so
the statement so you agree so you
strongly disagree that liverpool is a
bigger club what does that say
i strongly disagree okay then so that
means that's what i think then
arsene wenger
was a better manager than jurgen klopp
is now
three
two one
okay disagree he's not strongly disagree
basically um i disagree because the end
of part of the statement is right now so
i know obviously wenger's not coaching
right now
um but i think it's it's it's early to
judge sort of the legacy that you've
been clockwise so far i think jurgen
klopp the trajectory jurgen klopp's on
will make him um the greater manager so
he's not a great manager now
i
let me think
no
stick in here i think
i think i think one of the major major
issues i have with arsene wenger and
don't get me wrong again before i
continue because i think you may have
this image of me trying to dis oh
something arsene wenger was one of
like i saw
you know the job he done at arsenal he
revolutionized the game i'm even saying
that i just think a couple of things
hold
hold hold i hold against him is a the
fact that he didn't win the champions
league b he didn't do it sort of at
another major club then he's come to
liverpool again not one of the not one
of the top teams when he came to the
premier league and he was absolutely
terrible sleeping giants yeah super yeah
sleeping napping
more money
more money more money than us
uh
i disagree with the more money
absolutely disagree with it so how much
does van dyke cost
75 million
and that's a limited budget it is
comparing it is not a limited budget 75
million on one player sure i don't i
don't think we've spent i think we spent
72 million on nicholas nicholas nicholas
nixon's pepper that's our biggest size
sure so that's three million more
nicholas sure so i don't know if that's
a limited budget so i think that's i
think look you're not letting me give
the example of context behind it i've
literally told you we spent uh we we
sold coutinho to spend that kind of
money okay unless we sell one of our
major stars we haven't invested in a
player you're speaking about yeah
i don't wanna yeah we haven't we haven't
seen it
uh about 50 million but again i've just
literally told you 15 minutes so that's
125 225 million my massive very bad one
100 players yeah your math is on two
your match is that's as bad as mine
because i've literally told you katuni
will cost us 140 so we're still in
deficit the point i'm trying to make is
he's had to wheel and deal and he's done
a magnificent job his recruit his
signings have been immaculate we've had
to do this literally i don't know within
three years
within three within three years he's
turned around the whole
outlook of this club as fans
um everyone looks at us as one of the
super teams of the premier league in
europe probably right now um
we are i think
talking about one of the elite managers
by the time he finishes absolutely one
of the elite managers of all time but no
no
oh no i think he's a magnificent world
class manager i'm not i'm not a better
manager than the nation he was told and
i will quote you can quote me on this he
was told that you have to guarantee top
four football to get a loan he was told
that when he didn't know where we would
end up and he did that for 22 years so
don't diss the man don't disturb man
like i said clock has fantastic as
copies and i rate i rate club don't get
me wrong i rate clock i rate liverpool
yeah right so it's like them saying when
klopp comes in listen jurgen you have to
work within a budget you can't buy van
dyke you can't buy ellison we're
building a new stadium you've got to
guarantee that liverpool will be in the
top four
for the longs to come even though klopp
does not know where liverpool end up
this is why i'm saying he's a better
manager and all the time don't give all
the time keeping us in the top four keep
us in the top four against the mind let
me finish let me finish let me finish
and he gets to mike you said you said
which oligarch
against the might of chelsea i don't
know where my [ __ ] was and imagine it
against people who are spending more
money than us more money i think you've
contradicted yourself i'll tell you what
i'm about to tell you why because you've
literally called your invincible teams
the greatest the greatest so the full so
the fall off between the invincibles and
now you're saying
that we we we've remained in the top
four is quite a bit of a drop-off now
of course now
from a great height absolutely just like
you have and arson wenger and arsene
wenger had
as equally uh to do with that
as he had to creating that team would
you agree with that
only partly okay
we've got somewhere
else
yeah i have i was lucky enough to meet
him and he was absolutely the most
humble
intelligent
um polite person i've never been oh he's
a genius
he told he told us a lot of stuff but he
used to say that um
phil brown and adadise on the touchlines
always used to try and wind them up
that's why i don't have a lot i don't
have a lot of respect for phil brown and
the thing is i want lad bible lad bible
i'm not i don't want lad bible to have
anyone sue them i will take it upon me i
will call phil brown a liar i thought
phil brown and the chairman of han a lie
at that time the time when we beat hull
in fa cup and they tried to lie that
cesc spat out one of their players and
spy their team and then phil brown the
liar came out and said that it was a
storm in a teacup i will say again phil
brown is a liar and he owes us an
apology and i absorb lad bible of any
defamation i'm saying that and if phil
brown
thinks that what i'm saying is you feel
bad can sue me he is an absolute liar
well finally enough is your certified
because we've actually got phil brown
here
come here come here where's our apology
come in where is he
okay well that was absolutely fantastic
thank you and you can quote me on
calling phil brown and i stand by my
words
see guys guys guys you've got him so
aggressively worked up no no no no no no
i'm feeling i'm gonna get the after
effects like no no no no can't we calm
down like the next section
gerrard
was a better player
than patrick dude i knew this was coming
three
two one
i knew this was coming i knew this was
coming
i knew this i i genuinely thought that
we may agree
on why would you want on a footballing
um a football level before being living
here on this really why why would we
agree because look
i know you know your football
and some of the stuff that you said has
blown my mind today and i've oh thank
you very much
i have i have been um educated in a lot
of stuff oh wow well thank you very much
that's very kind but i'm not gonna even
let you say patrick vieira was a better
footballer well i'll say it i don't need
you i
if you notice in the statement there was
no specific role
there was no specific uh position yes it
was the the term was player yes
um so football player in terms of the
amount of role stephen gerrard could
employ incredible at an elite level
unbelievable uh in my humble opinion is
not much debate but i i the way you've
gone so there's not much debate so to
one side of the table i think there is a
debate to be had from you so go ahead
okay so there's so there's not much
debate though so then tell me then
in live in steven gerrard's career i'm
not dissing him because let's let let's
look at the um but i feel you're about
to i'm not no no i'm not gonna disturb
gerald i'm not gonna deceive let's look
at the story
a young local lad liverpool fan came up
the ranks to be a liverpool legend yeah
that's cool and also i think the next
liverpool manager when clock returns
it's written in the stars
a great fantastic song by tiny temple so
that's cool that's cool what i'm saying
is what i would say i'm not dissing
steven so what did steve and gerald win
compared to patrick would be the first
thing uh
patrick
one component component of a magnificent
a big a massive component one year that
remained invincible even though i had
those 12 drawers uh dinner with this
yeah
and all of that i had a gold trophy
the greatest in istanbul
yeah we we played against ac milan
against one of the all-time great ac
milan teams yeah a team that consisted
of maldini yeah um
kaka crespo
pierlo seidorf we're talking about
legends of the game absolutely this guy
single-handedly near enough
single-handedly i know it's a sport team
though i think i think it's a team sport
i don't know if you've seen me because
if i remember i know you didn't watch
the game
if i did once again
you said it was good
i have to do
if you speak about sort of he came up
against you talk about vieira came up
against keane
yeah steven chart
openly says
that one of his hardest
opponents was vieira yeah that's right
that's right that's right steven gerrard
throughout his career has never had the
pleasure of playing amongst the great
players the arsenal team had no that's
true that's true and therefore he's on
an individual basis in terms of a player
all-round player attacking defending
assists
right back he could literally as a
number 10 i think the complete player
without doubt in my humble opinion is
steven gerrard arsenal are the biggest
banter club in the league
three
two one
i'm going to shock you
oh you disagree wow okay
and this is
one point one debate one chat that we
may we are agreeing on yeah we are
because i've had this debate with a few
friends and and what are their teams and
i think i think
i think manchester united has become
oh they have has become the biggest
banter club oh that's overtaken
well i don't think we were ever a banter
club i don't think we're able to if
that's if that's your if that's the
thing no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no
no
no i don't think we're ever trying to
club that's coming from somebody that is
look we agree that you're no you're no
longer we weren't about to come we've
never been a banter cup we never will be
a banter club
we will never be a banter club i don't
care when are you finance got to say i
don't care what any fan has got then
there's nobody speaking
well
listen you're the judge
you're in charge of your mouth you're in
charge of your mouth
what we've
what we've won what we've done and
hopefully what we will do
does not make us advance club and people
could say whatever they want i would
just put you on the facts from the 1930s
with herbert chapman to the 19th yeah
neil with the 1980s with don howe with
the 1990s with george graham with stuart
houston with bruce ryok with austin and
to the 2000s with mikhail so that's what
i'm saying
nobody can call us a banter club and if
they want to call us work up that's fine
bring your facts because i've got all of
mine bring your facts even if us and
manchester united maybe you know you do
wanna i'm not doing well you can't call
these teams bank clubs you call us
banter clubs i can't believe i'm not
trying to different much like you call
us banner clubs when you raise our
history you go back like sam beckett in
quantum leap to when nothing happened
that's what you do if you can't erase
history you cannot call us a banner club
okay i'm at stanford bridge i don't know
what i don't know what the game was
coming out again chelsea fans come
chelsea fan comes up to me says to me oh
yeah you are still fine tv you you you
you live in love world i said do the
visibles they said yes goodbye that's it
so that's what i mean we're going to
talk about facts so no we're not about
to grab it and like i said i don't want
to defend much like they're not a banter
club as well because what we've won what
we've done what ferguson has done what
arson has done puts them to the
the greatest managers along with bill
shankly
jockstein in the hall of fame so no
we're not we've never been a banter club
and i don't know where this banter club
comes from and i love these people that
call us about come and bring your facts
because what i'm talking about is facts
it's not opinion it's fact opinion
bountiful that's opinion facts
i'm i'm just glad that i i agreed with
you
thank you very much thank you very much
[Music]
you can't choose
there's no relationship
we just see you when we want to be you
and that's it you can't say what you're
saying